comeback is in the cruise industry which
is beginning to chart a
post-pandemic way forward carnival
cruise line
plans to resume some voyages from u.s
ports in august
shortly after a no sale order from the
cdc
expires congress has launched an
investigation into how
carnival responded to the coronavirus
and as chris van cleave reports
royal caribbean faces its first lawsuit
over the death of a crew member
due to the virus the wrongful death
lawsuit was filed on behalf of 27 year
old
pujioko a housekeeping employee from
indonesia
the suit claims he contracted covet 19
on royal caribbean's
symphony of the seas getting sick only
after
passengers left the ship how prepared
were the cruise lines for dealing with
covet 19. it's very clear that the
entire cruise industry dramatically
mishandled
the entirety of this outbreak not only
as it relates to passengers but also as
the crew members
maritime attorney michael winkelmann
represents the man's family
i think had they taken the steps that
pretty much every single person
around the world was taken i don't think
he would be dead today had they
implemented proper social distancing
quarantines given proper
masks to everybody i think that fujioka
would still be alive today
the roughly 53 billion dollar cruise
industry has been in dry dock since
mid-march
after a number of highly publicized
coronavirus outbreaks polls show
more than one in five americans say
it'll be a year or longer before they'd
set foot on a cruise ship
but carnival is hoping to restart
service on eight vessels from ports in
florida and texas by late summer
saying it's submitted a plan to the
centers for disease control
are there people who actually want to
get on a cruise ship right now
the short answer is yes absolutely aaron
flurio from conde nast traveler says
bookings for cruises in 2021 appear
strong
but there will be changes on board when
they first
get on board there's going to be a lot
of temperature checks
people might be denied boarding they
don't have proper medical notes
they're probably not going to be able to
plate their own food anymore lots of
things are not going to be shared that
used to be shared
but before those ships take on
passengers congress has some questions
the chairman of the house transportation
committee sent this letter to carnival
demanding information about its response
to coronavirus
and there's another issue more than 100
u.s citizens working on cruise ships
that cannot come home
the cdc won't allow them to disembark
until cruise lines agree to a plan
to get them home and quarantined why
can't you go home
i don't know cruise ship performer ryan
driscoll has been essentially stranded
at sea
for 60 days his ship hasn't seen
passengers
since mid-march and bottom line he'd
like to go home yeah
i'd like to go home yes of course um i'd
like to
be out of this room uh you know i've
been stuck in this box
for far too long and have major cabin
fever
and miss my family now royal caribbean
declined comment on the lawsuit but says
it has
reached an agreement with the cdc to
start bringing home its american crew
members that should start happening this
week
carnival says it will comply with the
congressional investigation and is still
working with the cdc
on a plan to bring home americans like
ryan the cdc says
it does not have enough information yet
to know if the cruise line's plans to
resume
service are safe enough gail
boy feeling for ryan driscoll and
everybody else in his situation right
now chris but before you go
you sort of asked it in the in your
piece i was wondering the same thing
is there a demand for people to go on a
cruise ship at this time in
in summer and who are these people what
are you hearing
what we're hearing is that advanced
bookings for 2021
are relatively strong you have to
balance that with at least 10 percent of
people in a recent survey said they will
never get on a cruise ship
ever again
it'll be interesting to see the turnout
that they have thank you chris van cleef